when we're on the set right now of Jeff
1000 which is about his life you know
since his career is really taking off
he's want to sort of document that
hi and Jeff and I am a robot I used to
be an automotive assembly device up what
I always wanted to do what my heart told
me to do was to be an actor so i got
this series called f1000 it's about me
the work is it's exciting it's fun it's
challenging it endlessly surprising for
everyone involved I have no idea where
Jeff came from I assumed China I've
never cast a robot before I assume it's
we should get some points with that
right we should get some money back I
don't know her Silicon Valley maybe I
don't know I don't know what the yes Oh
David school decat he's the best yeah
we're really good friends really good
you know I've worked with a lot of
actors and every actor they have their
own little nuances he's all good because
he's large isn't this an issue you know
like I have problems getting him into
cars we just need to plan carefully like
where Jeff can and can't go but from a
performance point of view it's like the
same thing I say about like Wesley
Snipes good actor that's what I say
about Jeff Wesley Snipes good actors you
know some people don't want to work with
a robot they're just it we're just not
there yet but then there's people like
summer hi I'm I'm summer glau working
with jeff has been it's been a
revelation I mean I I can honestly say
that I have never worked with someone
like him before various Jeff please just
told me alone okay I I will not leave
you long we've been talking about these
different projects for a while and Jeff
really wanted to tell his own story I
wanted to be a part of that Jeff and I
really do have something something
special we take care of each other you
know of a set you just you can't ask for
a better same partner first of all don't
know if you know how hilarious he is I'm
sorry i forgot the line user error 04
not
working with him I I just I've ruined so
him and he takes because he makes me
laugh he's charming funny ouch joy to
work with some of his onset pranks have
been downright hilarious I'd ordered
some lemonade from you know a restaurant
for lunch and I took a taste and it was
actually coca-cola and that was Jeff he
did that he he switched out the lemonade
for coca-cola and I was like I'll be
damned I mean I like to have fun you
know I'd to take work seriously but not
take myself too seriously and I like to
give the director he loves it too Jeff
get the out of my trailer sorry I i put
he's been back and forth in there all
day long I have absolutely no he's not
always the easiest guy to work with I
mean he's not perfect who is perfect
it's like you have to wait to say your
line tilly like meee you have to make
sure he computes am i doing a good job i
think so i think i hope so in terms of
you know creative criticism about his
acting he's a little bit sensitive and I
don't push it cuz you could you know
incinerate me it records everything his
eyes it's like cameras I gotta I gotta
go i member once Jeff was called on to
set and he lumbers on to set and there's
a PA in his way he literally stepped on
he stepped on this guy and uh yeah he
didn't he didn't make it but um that's
Jeff you know for Hollywood to give me
the green light for my own serious
that's it's a really big thing for the
whole robot community your time is over
children's I don't know a single person
who doesn't wonder what's it like to be
an evil robot from another planet and he
brings us into that he lets us
experience that Jeff is his own creation
he's his own individual yeah he's really
special to me
I hope Jeff smart enough to enjoy his
moment in the Sun in the spotlight
because this town will chew you up and
spit you out quicker than one of those
you know car machinist who literally
crushed the guards into little boxes
which will probably happen to Jeff and
support